we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p this caller
is expressing concern over the portion
of Trumpets that just think trump russia
is no big deal how do you give people to
believe this russian story is actually a
big deal
somehow over 70% of trump voters don't
believe that this is a new story limited
this makes me think that they won't
actually prosecute trumpet The Smoking
Gun finally does come out I mean what
can you do that apparently what they're
doing is working a lot of people don't
believe this story what do you think
yeah what can we do listen you can't do
much sadly there are ideologically
committed trumpets who you know sort of
I I think even if you showed them video
of Trump and Putin personally
collaborating on something sinister they
would say the video was doctored I don't
know that we need to worry too much
about convincing the ideologically
committed trumpets and some on the Left
who are also ideologically committed to
the idea that there's just nothing to
see here with Crump Russia it doesn't
matter because we ultimately just need
to see what the investigations turn up
and hopefully Robert Moeller will be
doing a full and complete investigation
and the real issue is how will
Republicans in the House and Senate be
influenced by public opinion because
ultimately it is they who would have to
decide about Trump impeachment and that
is why if public opinion is strongly or
at least in some sectors strong that
there's no big deal that is actually
something that could affect Republicans
and saying we're not even going to deal
with impeachment it does seem as if this
Russia stories affecting Donald Trump's
approval numbers because we saw after
the Don junior meeting they went down to
around 36% correct but it's not really
hitting him hard in Trump country and
like this caller suggests it's not
really a story to them so I don't know
if the democratic approach is to just
ignore his base and try to win over
independence people in the middle for
the next few election cycles or what
from an electoral perspective I think so
I've said before you can the amount of
time it will take you to convince one
trumpet you could register ten people
the vote right so or maybe even more
I've met some crumpets that it would
take a while if at all so I think Alec
Tory that absolutely if you have the
country doesn't vote I think there's a
good amount of opportunity to no doubt
about it on the bonus show today Chile
has converted 11 million acres into new
national parks a suicidal man that had
doused himself in gasoline caught fire
because police tasered him we will talk
about that on the bonus show today and a
new report has found asbestos in makeup
sold to young kids at stores this is a
chain called justice which is not a
chain that I was familiar with up until
I read about this report I don't think
we have them up here in the North East
they're working as best as they can as
best as they can they're doing yeah
that's pretty clever mark that down
folks the day that Pat did a incredible
pun on the David Pakman show
July what day is it 19 18 and I think
the 19 who even knows what day it is at
this point all of those stories and more
on the bonus show get the
commercial-free access pass and instant
access to the bonus show when you sign
up at david pakman.com slash membership
we depend on your support thank you to
everyone who has signed up in July which
is tracking to be a great month for new
members you can also make a pledge of as
little as one dollar a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show by
all means I invite you to join me on the
bonus show